is there a difference between
intellectually knowing Free Will is an
illusion and really experiencing it yeah
yeah what's the what's the longest
you've been able to experience the uh
escape the illusion if you will well
it's always I it's always obvious to me
when I pay attention I mean when I
whenever I'm mindful the the term of
jargon you know in the Buddhist and and
increasingly you know outside the
Buddhist context is is mindfulness right
but they're sort of different levels of
mindfulness and there's there's
different um
degrees of insight into this but yes I
mean what I'm calling evidence of lack
of Free Will and lack of you know lack
of the self and I got two sides of the
same coin there's a sense of being
a subject in the middle of experience to
whom all experience refers the sense of
I the sense of me
and that's almost everybody's starting
point when they they start to meditate
and that's almost always the place
people live most of their lives from I
do think that gets interrupted in ways
that get unrecognized I think people are
constantly losing the sense of I they're
losing the sense of subject object
distance
but they're not recognizing it and and
meditation is
the mode in which you can recognize you
can you can both consciously precipitate
it you can look for the self and fail to
find it and then recognize its absence
and that's the just the flip side of the
coin of free will I mean the the the
feeling of having free will is what it
feels like to feel like a self
who's thinking his thoughts and doing
his actions and intending his intentions
and he the the man in the middle of the
boat who's Rowan
um
that's the story that's the false
starting point when you find that
there's no one in the middle of the boat
right or in fact there's no boat there's
just the river there's just the flow of
experience
and there's no Center to it and there's
no place from which you would control it
again even when you're doing things this
does not negate the difference between
voluntary and involuntary Behavior it's
like
I can voluntarily reach for this but
when I'm paying attention I'm aware that
everything is just happening like just
the intention to move is just a rising
right and
I'm in no position I don't know why I
didn't arise a moment before or a moment
later or a moment or or you know
50 stronger or weaker or you know so as
to be ineffective or to be doubly
effective where I lurched for it versus
I moved slow I mean I'm not
I can never run the counter factuals I
can never all this opens the door to a
and even more disconcerting picture
along the same lines which is
subsumes this conversation about Free
Will and it's the question of whether
anything is ever possible like what if
this is a question I I haven't thought a
lot of about it but
it's been a few years I've been kicking
this question around
um
so I mean what if only the actual
is possible would it what if there was
what if it was do we live with this
feeling of possibility we live with a
sense that
let me take it so you know I have two
daughters
I could have had a third child right so
what does it mean to say that I could
have had a third child right so do you
you don't have kids I don't think so not
that I know of yes so the possibility
might be there so what do we mean when
we say you could have had a child or
you might you you might have a child in
the future like what what what is the
space in real what's the relationship
between possibility and actuality and
reality is there a reality in which
non-actual things
are nonetheless real and so there we
have other categories of like non
concrete things we have things that
don't have spatial temporal Dimension
but they're nonetheless they nonetheless
exist so like you know in the integers
right so numbers
there's a there's a reality there's an
abstract reality to numbers and this is
it's philosophically interesting to
think about these things so they're not
like in some sense they're
they're
real
and they're just they're not merely
invented by us they're discovered
because they have structure that we
can't impose upon them right it's not
like they're not fictional characters
like you know I mean Hamlet and Superman
also exist in some sense but they exist
at the level of of Our Own
fiction and abstraction but it's like
they're true they're true and false
statements you can make about Hamlet
they're true and false statements you
can make about Superman because our
fiction the fictional worlds we've
created have a certain kind of structure
but again this is all abstract it's like
it's all abstractable from any of its
concrete instantiations it's not just in
the comic books and just in the movies
it's in our you know ongoing ideas about
these characters
but natural numbers or
um
the integers don't
function quite that way I mean they're
similar but they also have a structure
that's purely a matter of Discovery it's
not you can't just make up whether
numbers are prime
you know if you give me two integers you
know of a certain size to let's you
mentioned two enormous integers
if I were to say okay well between those
two integers they're exactly 11 prime
numbers right that's a very specific
Claim about which I can be right or
wrong and whether or not anyone knows
I'm writers like that's just there's a
domain of facts there these are abstract
it's an abstract reality that relates in
some way that's philosophically
interesting you know metaphysically
interesting too
what we call real reality you know this
the spatial temporal order
the physics of things
but
possibility at least in my view occupies
a different space and this is something
again I my thoughts on this are pretty
in code and I I think I need to talk to
a philosopher of physics and and or
physicist about how this may interact
with with things like the many worlds
interpretation yeah that's an
interesting like right exactly so I I
wonder if discover is in physics like
further proof or more concrete proof
that many was interpretation of quantum
Organics has some validity right if that
completely starts to change things but
even that that's just more
actuality so if I took that seriously ah
sure that's that's the case of
and and Truth is that happens even even
if the many worlds interpretation isn't
true but we just imagine we have a
physically infinite universe
the implication of infinity is such that
things will begin to repeat themselves
you know the farther you go in space
right so the you know if if you just
head out in One Direction eventually
you're going to meet two people just
like us having a conversation just like
this and you're going to meet them an
infinite number of times in every you
know infinite variety of permutations
slightly different from this
conversation right so I mean Infinity is
just so big that our intuitions of
probability completely break down
but what I'm suggesting is
maybe probability isn't a thing right
maybe there's only actuality if there's
maybe there's only what happens
and at every point along the way
our notion of what could have happened
or what might have happened is just that
it's just a thought about what could
have happened or might there's no so
it's a fundamentally different thing if
you can imagine a thing that doesn't
make it real
so they because that's that's where that
possibility exists is in your
imagination right yeah and possibility
itself is a kind of spooky idea because
it it too has a sort of structure
right so like if I if I'm going to say
you know
you could have had a daughter right last
year
um
so we're saying that's that's possible
but not actual
right that is a claim they're things
that
are true and not true about that
daughter right like that it has a kind
of structure it's like
I feel like there's a lot of fog around
that the possibility it feels like
almost like a useful narrative but what
does it mean so like
what does it mean if if we say you know
I just did that but I'm it's conceivable
that I wouldn't have done that right
like it's possible that I I just threw
this cap but I might not have done that
so you're taking it very temporarily
close to the original like what would
appear as a decision
whenever we're saying something's
possible but not actual right like this
thing just happened but it's conceived
it's possible that it wouldn't have
happened or it would have happened
differently
in what does that possibility
consist like where is that what it for
that to be real for the possibility to
be real
what are we what claim are we making
about
the universe well isn't that an
extension of the idea that Free Will is
an illusion that all we have is
sexuality that the possibility isn't
right yeah I'm just extending it Beyond
is this Human Action uh like it's it's
this goes to the physics of things this
is just everything like we're always
telling ourselves a story yeah that
includes possibility possibility is
really compelling for some reason
well yeah well because it's it's
I mean so this yeah I mean this could
sound just academic but it every
backward looking regret or
disappointment and every forward-looking
worry
is completely dependent on this notion
of possibility like every regret is
based on the sense that something else I
could have done something else something
else could have happened every
disposition to worry about the future
is based on the feeling that there's
this range of possibilities it could go
either way
and
you know I I know whether whether or not
there's such a thing as possibility you
know I'm convinced that worry is Almost
Never
psychologically
appropriate because the reality is in
any given moment
either you can do something to solve the
problem you're worried about or not so
if you can do something just do it you
know and if you can't you're worrying is
just causing you to suffer twice over
right you're gonna
you know you're gonna you're gonna get
the medical procedure next week anyway
how much time between now and next week
do you want to spend worrying about it
right it's gonna it's the worry the
worry doesn't accomplish anything